cut from the same cloth that's the focus
of tonight's mini angle
last november we posed a very simple
question to congresswoman alexander
ocasio-cortez do you really want to be
taken seriously or is this all about
just enhancing your brand
so it's going to be interesting to see
aoc's next move
in the last few months the establishment
has shown her the carrot the cover of
vanity fair of course and the stick
leaks about how aoc is hurting the
democrat party choice is hers
and she'll have to make it soon
by working with the populace she can
really help working people
and for many folks
that's even better than being on the
cover of vogue or vanity fair it was a
genuine question and 10 months later we
have an answer
we really started having a conversation
about what it means to be
working class women of color at the met
and we said you know we can't just play
along but we need to break the fourth
wall and challenge some of the
institutions and
and
you know while
the met is known for its spectacle we
should have a conversation about it
being a working-class woman at the met
okay the irony of attending this gal or
tickets cost 30k
each uh it's not lost on anyone and
neither should the fact that whichever
rich snob paid for her ticket will get
to write it off now many of her critics
say this speaks to her total lack of
self-awareness but i actually disagree
she knows exactly what she's doing
she relishes the limelight and is
obsessed with her image as the left's
chic social justice queen or princess
in a way she's really not all that
different though from another massive
narcissist of the moment of course
anthony fauci when you look at crowds
like that you approve of that or is that
just not smart
no i don't think it's smart smart people
i know that i talk to who say
i'm healthy i'm this age i've never been
sick i don't need to get the vaccine you
are a part of society and you do have
some responsibility as a member of
society
oh really anthony of course since the
meeting media feeds off your misery the
fawning of rafachi has only gotten worse
just yesterday the guardian put up this
brooding photo of fauci the caption
reading
the us diseases expert has been spoofed
by brad pitt and lauded as the sexiest
man alive
now in the accompanying article the
guardian quoted a fouchy admirer saying
i have not known anyone with more
humility in my lifetime
how many times though has factory lied
or been called out then light again
he's a duplicit a snake who only cares
about holding on to power
and in that sense
he and aoc
are kind of kindred spirits they've
mastered the art of public manipulation
through their preferred chosen mediums
their currencies magazine covers social
media cable hits
certainly saving lives or really
standing up for the working people as
they claim to in a way though i think we
should feel kind of fortunate that these
two moments happened in unison
the masks are off and it's time that the
cameras start training on the people who
actually care about their fellow
americans hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else